holy crap guys this has to be one of the
best episodes yet and there's so much to
unpack here so we're gonna get right
into it the episode starts with Ruth
Deaver running into the shed surrounded
by figures of the nativity scene which
provides a chilling juxtaposition
between life nativity and death Ruth
holds a revolver as someone is about to
enter before it cuts to a flashback we
see the same scene from episode five but
now played out through different angles
you'll notice this technique is used
several times to shed new light on
scenes from previous episodes in this
one notice how the dog gets a more
prominent shot setting up his eventual
death the hands of the truck and Allen's
knife
Ruth lays out a piece of luggage to act
as a makeshift coffin she wants the dog
to have a proper burial unlike her old
dog puck who she believes her husband
Matthew poisoned puck is also the name
of a demon sometimes fairy-like
character in English folklore Ruth has a
nightmare where a dead squirrel appears
by her bed just like puck used to leave
on her pillow like hotel mints she
awakens to find puck they're covered in
squirrel blood until she heads into the
hallway to find the blood from her hand
has disappeared and she's in new clothes
this is something that happened several
times in the episode where she drifts
from places in time from reality to the
past or from memory to memory when she
comes downstairs we see Henry and Alan
having the same conversation from
episode 1 but this time we're seeing it
from Ruth's perspective she's forgotten
the sheets
notice how the banisters here look like
the top of a Queen's chess piece and
again here later on in the episode the
Queen is not only the name of this
episode but a recurring theme throughout
it while getting the sheets Ruth eyes
the revolver the same one from the
beginning of the episode before we cut
to dr. Vargas's office who recommends
Alan's start thinking about arrangements
for Ruth Alan tries to get Ruth to
remember the word from her psychological
tests clock by reciting the nursery
rhyme hickory dickory dock the mouse ran
up the blank and since time plays such
an important role in this episode it's
no wonder the word is clock back in
reality Ruth picks up the chess set and
takes out the Queen and Knight the Queen
representing her and the knight
representing Alan which will see more
poignant Lee later on Ruth goes
throughout the house
down chess pieces and experiencing
flashbacks the first is of her reading
Hansel and Gretel two young Henry she
reads one of the scenes in which the
parents try to abandon their children in
the woods possibly an allusion to
Matthew in Henry in the forest in the
next scene Ruth watches her conversation
with Henry from episode 2 putting a
chess piece in the cabinet before we
transition to Alan teaching Ruth the
French drop a magic technique involving
sleight of hand
remember in Episode five how the writers
set up Alan's love for magic not only
that but episode six set up Ruth looking
at something in the corner here we now
know it was this memory of her and Alan
another scene we've seen before shows
Wendell looking over the program from
his grandfather's reburial we hear again
the line from Corinthians before
transitioning to Matthew Deaver giving a
sermon Alan and Ruth share a look
hinting at their love affair while the
rest of the Bible passage plays in the
background and this Bible passage is
starting to hint at a new theory which
I'll divulge later on in the video the
hymn which ends the scene is the same
one the kid plays on the piano in
episode 5 Oh God our help in ages past
it transitions us to Ruth daydreaming
which we saw in episode 6 after staring
at the kid Ruth finds the ground filled
with autumn leaves which leads us to the
worst picnic ever
Matthew takes out a pistol and tells
them how he almost killed himself
because he couldn't understand how God
could allow all this suffering he needed
proof that God was there so he put a gun
to his head and asked to hear his voice
which miraculously he did this is an
interesting piece of information because
it shows Ruth was likely lying to Henry
in the last episode when he questioned
her about Matthew hearing voices in the
woods Matthew also brings up the story
of Saul's conversion to Paul from the
book of Acts in the Bible in which the
non-believer Saul hears the voice of God
and converts to be one of Jesus's most
devout followers changing his name to
Paul in the process Matthew asks Henry
if he can hear it which he says no Ruth
looks at the chess piece in ting that
she's not in reality
remember the pieces help ground her
acting as her breadcrumbs just like what
Hansel and Gretel used to find their way
back home now this might be the most
important scene the episode at least in
terms of unlocking the mystery of Castle
Rock Wendel explains his video
game-2 Ruth telling her that she's like
a time Walker time walkers are the most
powerful characters in the game because
they're the only ones that can kill the
dead for good and these dead can take
the form of even your most trusted
allies the term I've heard tossed around
is skinwalkers by being able to
constantly slip into different skins you
can achieve immortality is that what
Mathieu Deaver was attempting look back
at the passage from Corinthians for the
perishable body must put on the
imperishable and this mortal body must
put on the immortal you can live
immortal by shedding the skin of
different vessels or bodies consider
what the pastor calls Matthew's body in
episode 6 he says recommit that pause is
very deliberate is the kids some form of
this skinwalker fully in tune with the
skismo when he touches another he's able
to take control of their body like what
he did to Zaleski de Lacy and what he'll
later make Ruth do the only person that
can kill one of these entities is a time
Walker for no one stays dead until you
kill him unless you're a time Walker
harkening back to what Ruth said in
episode 5 nothing stays dead in this
town back in reality we see the scene
from episode 6 where the kid comes in
but this time from Ruth's perspective
and it's Matthew who enters she leaves
the room and finds the news showing the
kids face as the one wanted for the
Juniper Hill fire also check out the
cross which hangs in the wall the same
spot where the kids saw it not hanging
in episode six
it seems our kid fancies himself a
decorator as we'll see later on
Ruth fearing for a life grabs the gun
but can't find the bullets in one of the
weirdest scenes of the episode young
Henry watches her mom take a bath as
they play a game of guess which
Icelandic folklore character I am of
course she chose Thor tiss from the Giz
Lasogga a woman who was fought over by
two men Matthew and Alan anyone Matthew
comes in and for a brief moment we see
him take what appears to be an aspirin
hinting that he is still suffering from
the ringing in his ear he tells her not
to worry about Henry getting the gun
he's got the bullets locked away back in
the present Ruth searches for the
bullets by attempting to pry a safe in
the Attic
she's interrupted by Molly at the
door Molly senses something is wrong
with Henry likely because he's currently
experiencing the anechoic chamber we saw
last episode Roose says she remembers
Molly killing Matthew but it didn't take
he's back and she's going to fix it fix
it by killing the kid back in the house
it looks like the kid has done some more
redecorating by adding the smash family
picture to the dining room
Ruth questions the kid trying to get to
the bottom of who he really is now is he
Matthew young Henry or something
entirely different let's take a look at
what the kid knows he knows blue moon
was played at their wedding the
combination for the safe upstairs is
Ruth's birthday and that a ritual after
dinner was to draw a bath these are all
things both Matthew and young Henry
could have theoretically known not to
mention the kid uses the word your
husband instead of I whether that's to
throw her off the scent of him being
Matthew we just don't know yet and in
one of the most shocking moments of the
episode Ruth and the kid touch and we
know what happens to everything that kid
touches the kid offers to make her
something to eat she uses this time - uh
sure Wendell off to the mall so she can
continue looking for the bullets the kid
confronts Ruth about where Wendell went
notice how he's holding the monitor in
his hand we'll see this later on - when
he's in the bathroom
has he been watching her and if so for
how long
in a flashback Ruth takes young Henry's
temperature noticed that this happened
before the events of the disappearance
in 1991 and there are no Tasmanian Devil
sheets like in previous episodes henry
is faking an illness but not for school
to ditch his father who's been taking
him out in the woods at weird hours of
the night Henry tells Ruth that Matthew
has been teaching him what exactly we
don't know she suggests he tell him that
he hears the voice in the woods even if
he doesn't in order to please him Ruth
goes to young Allen pang more under the
pretenses that puck has gone missing but
really it's about Matthew she's wanting
to leave him but can't stand to leave
Henry - he tells her to pack her bag
before they're interrupted and we have
this beautiful transition from what
appears to be the police hallway into
her own home in the kitchen she stumbles
upon the rat poison supposedly used by
Matthew to kill puck if you listen
closely you can even hear the flies near
the dog bowl outside you can see the
turkey vultures hovering over what
likely her dead dog back in the present
the kid has made her something to eat
and also knows how she likes her eggs he
finds her pills in the garbage
hydrocodone a form of vicodin used to
treat severe pain he passes her the pill
to take reciting the same line she told
Matthew in the past god helps those who
help themselves in the background you
can hear a song playing with the lyrics
some people never die and time where did
you go I also find it interesting how
the kid reacts to drawing the bath it
isn't sexual at all more like someone
who is happy to help this leads me to
believe more so that he's in tune with
young Henry then Matthew the kid goes
off to draw the bath and we learned Ruth
used the French drop palming technique
she was taught by Alan to palm the pill
Ruth goes back to the safe now knowing
the combo it's her birthday but here's
the weird thing
the combo she uses is 120 240 making her
birthday January 22nd 1941 make her 51
at the time of henry's disappearance and
she does not look 51 back then what if
at some point in Ruth's life she had the
power of non-agent just like the kid I
know it's pretty crazy but it would
explain this discrepancy the safe
doesn't have the bullets but there are a
few other interesting items one a letter
looking a lot like what the kid found in
Matthews suitcase in episode 6 a
passport and a jewelry box
perhaps containing the ring we briefly
saw in Henry's flashes in an anechoic
chamber we then have a really weird cut
where Ruth has somehow made her way
inside the bath when the kid confronts
her she asks who are you to which she
responds I'm smaller than a teacup the
same thing young Henry said to her
earlier on in the episode Ruth stabs the
kid with the screwdriver and rushes out
into the hallway which is filled with
those attending what appears to be her
husband's wake one lady even saying
you're still young you'll remarry again
pointing at the fact that she probably
wasn't 51 at the time but as she
ventures further into the crowd so does
her memory back in time people celebrate
and one man says it was a lovely wedding
Frank Sinatra's come fly with me plays
in the background a song that came out
in 1958 Ruth locks herself in Henry's
room and watches herself as she packs
the suitcase Allen told her to prepare
but
or she snapped back into a different
time and what appears to be again the
wake of her husband's funeral
check out the pile of rocks over here
very odd but a deliberate placement
choice if you know what they're for or
might symbolize please leave a comment
below
we then see a girl who looks like she
could be a very young version of Ruth in
fact when a woman's voice calls Ruth
both of them turned in that person's
direction
Ruth sees Allen hanging by the casket
and she asks if it's her in there before
turning and seeing the younger version
of herself sobbing implying that this is
indeed the wake of her husband but we
can never be sure nothing is what it
seems in Castle Rock and we have yet to
see who is actually in that casket
Matthew and Henry arrived home after one
of their excursions Ruth chastises
Matthew with a line she recites in
episode 6 saying he's got a fever
Matthew you're gonna kill him out there
Matthew rushes past her rubbing his head
the headaches most likely Ruth tells him
that she made Henri lie about hearing
the voice but Henri says he did hear it
or is he just protecting her Ruth tells
him she's going to leave but Matthew
says she can't because she didn't back
then she can't change what was already
done but their altercation makes her
remember the bullet she kept in the
luggage the same one used to bury puck
back in the present she rushes to the
back yard and digs up the bullets as the
kid watches from the second-floor window
then the story starts where the episode
began the shed Ruth experiences more and
more voices in her head a cacophony of
sounds in fear of her life she fires as
an unknown figure enters accidentally
killing Allen the shed filled with
Nativity figures symbolizing life and
birth is now tainted with death Ruth
goes back into the house and showers
likely in shocked by the events that
just transpired
we then see her prepare for a new day
and this is likely in her head since
when the doorbell rings she primps her
hair full well knowing who it will be on
the other end it's alan and we hear him
say the story he told Henry in the
hospital in episode 5 the story of how
he came back to her the to embrace as
the last shot is of a queen up right
next to its downed night Ruth and Alan
both white both on the same side it's
unclear whether Alan will be back
nothing stays dead in this town after
all
unless of course it's killed by a time
walker and has Ruth changed her time
line we'll just have to tune in next
week to see how the fallout from this
episode affects everyone in Castle Rock
I hope you enjoyed this video make sure
to LIKE and subscribe until next week